you know a quick little message for my
fans people are not my fans and people
out there
I want from broke to be richest in the
matter the end and all this money all
this money can't buy happiness and take
it from me I've been broke brothers and
sisters in Islam a lot of you are
familiar with me being alone for Bad Boy
Records and a lot of y'all familiar with
some of you know the ills that come with
being in the music business but when I
elaborate elaborate on my past
you know lifestyle and the things that
I've done is never to entertain you or
ever to persuade you to follow in these
and in these steps because the lifestyle
that I was living prior to Islam was a
very sinful lifestyle I spent 24 hours
of my life 24 hours a day and a
consistent cycle of sinning and doing
things that were only setting me up for
destruction and dying in this state but
I only landed me in the Hellfire for an
eternity so by a large mercy I was
guided into the fold of Islam but some
of the things that I did hamdulillah I'm
never going to be proud of is not
something that I wear as a badge of
honor or to show that hey look at me I
was jah-el and Allah guided me know
every day I tried to implement and
exercise gratitude for a lot of mercy
being bestowed upon me and guiding me
into the fold of Islam and a lot of
since I've been a Muslim in a short
period of time I've noticed that a lot
of the Muslim youth who are striving to
engage in some of these sinful acts that
I used to commit with
no knowledge with no knowledge and to
know that you most of you who are born
and raised Muslim and have a clear
understanding of the punishment of the
Hellfire have the clear understanding of
dying in the state of Khufu and have a
clear understanding of dying in the
state of sin without repenting for these
sins the punishment and the anger that a
loss upon a lot that Allah has for those
who fall into this state is beyond
understanding it's something that you
cannot fathom in your mind and a lot of
times your young brothers and sisters
think just because you speak or you know
Leyla hail Allah Muhammad Rasul Allah
you believe that this statement is
something that is going to justify you
know your actions or your bad deeds no
and a lot of you young brothers and
sisters believe that you can handle the
Hellfire you know a lot of y'all have
this misconception is because I'm Muslim
I'm born Muslim and I believe Leila hail
O Muhammad also the law I'm saved from
the fire yes but it does not make you
exempt from the punishment of the
Hellfire and in most cases you can't
even sit in a hot house in the
summertime without the a/c without being
bothered by that miniscule level of heat
and when you think of the Hellfire and
spending just 5 minutes 5 seconds in
this fire that I lost a part of what the
Allah has created for the disbelievers
that he has created to punish even the
believers who commit sins against you
know st. olaf's praying to Allah and his
beautiful religion of Islam I just want
to let you know as a reminder for myself
first and foremost for all the young
brothers and sisters out there be very
mindful of the consequences of these
deeds that I used to perform be
constantly be mindful of you know the
path that these bad deeds were leading
me to and be grateful not only for your
brother in Islam but be grateful for
yourself that a loss upon order Allah
guided you to Islam as a mercy and as a
means to safeguard yourself from the
punished
of the Hellfire and every day that I
lost the pen owatta Allah wakes me up
and breathe air in my lungs and gives me
another opportunity to worship Him and
him alone and associate no partners in
any form or actively badda this is the
responsibility and this is an image from
Allah this is something that is it is
only given by His mercy so you know when
I was you know guided to Islam and
understand in totality the beauty and
benefit in the reward that comes with
worship in the law I was quickly able to
abstain from every negative act I was
able to extend from every major sin I
used to commit I was quickly able to
detach myself from some of the most
detrimental aspects of the dunya only to
seize the opportunity a worship of
worshipping allah subhanaw taala and
standing firm and charlotta allah on the
right path and the path for the prophet
started selling in no sense and stealing
the path of the quran and the sunnah by
way of the understanding of the
Companions of The Messenger of Allah so
like someone and once this understanding
was established with me I held on tight
to it I try every day know and I strive
harder and harder every day to try to
stay firm upon this understanding
because this is the straight path this
is the only means of earning the mercy
of Allah when Allah Ta'ala on the day on
mukaiyama when we are all resurrected
and I understand the counter for good
and bad deeds so you know Milazzo
playing about the allah keep all of us
firm upon what is correct my lifespan
with the allah you know grant us success
and grant us the opportunity to die in
the state of tawheed to die in the state
of islam and not to fall short from this
victory that allah has promised to
believers
you know he promised us you know by his
mercy to enter his his paradise and
endure pleasure upon pleasure so there's
nothing that could substitute this
there's no other alternative that can
get you there it's a hardy for the
profits are selling me said if you are
held up and entering the gates of genda
your lineage will not get you there any
faster so do not lean on the fact that
you were born Muslim born in an out of
country born in the predominately Muslim
you know saying country or you know
anywhere that you know establishes your
birthright of being a Muslim this does
not make you accept exempt for falling
into the state of Khufu it does not make
you exempt from the punishment of the
Hellfire and this is something that is a
combat upon every Muslim whether you're
born Muslim or reverted to Islam it's to
stay firm and yet in your worship to
allah subhana wa ta'ala is stay away
from with a law prohibited in Hastings
what Allah has made permissible and all
I want to do is urge you to definitely
never give up studying the religion of
Islam just because Islam may be a
birthright maybe because you know you
were born Muslim you feel the urge to
neglect learning or seeking knowledge of
Islam this is something that is it's a
combination of our religion because
Islam is not it's not it's not a fashion
statement as Lomb is not something that
you know you just wear on your sleeve
and don't wear in your heart you know
Aslam is something that we have to edge
in our hearts as if we edge you know
words into stone
whether you wash them you know saying
wipe across them this does not you know
remove from a stone so this is what we
need to edge in our hearts is
you know ferm disappoint to heed the
understanding of tawheed understanding
of singling out along to island or acts
of worship we need to educate our hearts
you know the Quran we need to constantly
read and understand and learn the Book
of Allah in order to learn who our Lord
is we also need to implement to the best
of our ability to Sunnah of the Prophet
so like supplemented companions and we
need to stay firm upon these things no
matter what we do whether you're
studying in the university whether your
time is being preoccupied with work or
whatever the case may be always try to
establish that firm balance between Dean
and dunya because you do not want your
life to consist of more dunya and deen
so definitely i urge all of you for
around the world bury yourself in those
books keep you know keep keep your own
you know yourself busy with reading
understanding and memorizing quran
reading and understanding and memorizing
Touhey understanding the seven
conditions of laila halo law they note a
lot also three fundamental principles of
islam all these basic fundamental
principles islam is it is key to
building the foundation of your
understanding of the religion because
this is not something that you could
just learn at home without going back to
the book and the singer and the lord
knows best it's exactly my finest salam
why they can what happened to over the
cat subscribe to the dgo follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
[Music]